WE FIGHT," FOX NEWS NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGIST SEBASTIAN
GORKA.
I'M LOOKING AT THIS, THEY WERE
QUIET ABOUT ALL OF THIS WHEN
SARAH SANDERS, PAM BONDI,
SECRETARY NIELSEN, TWO
REPUBLICANS PUNCHED, WHEN A
WOMAN IN MINNESOTA, ROCKS THROWN
THROUGH KEVIN McCARTHY'S
OFFICE, TED CRUZ, TED CRUZ'S
WIFE, YOU SEE THESE TACTICS,
DOWN, SOMEBODY IS GOING TO GET
HURT.
THEY EVEN SCREAMED "MAIL
BOMBING," "WE KNOW WHERE YOU
SLEEP."
THAT IS A THREAT.
SHOULDN'T THAT BE AGAINST THE
LAW?
>> ABSOLUTELY, THEY VANDALIZED
HIS HOUSE, SEAN.
IT IS WAS GROSS.
THIS WAS DISGUSTING.
THIS WAS FILTHY.
BUT SEAN, I HAVE PERSONAL
EXPENSE WITH THIS, I HAVE BEEN
IN YOUR STUDIO IN NEW YORK, AND
I HAVE BEEN IN TUCKER'S IN D.C.
MANY TIME, I'VE BEEN ON YOUR
SITE WITH LIBERALS.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME SPICY
DEBATES ON YOUR SIDE, AND YOU
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IN THE GREEN
ROOM?
EVERYBODY SHAKES HANDS AND SAID
I WILL SEE THE NEXT TIME.
THERE'S GOT TO BE A REDLINE
HERE.
I APPRECIATE SOME OF THE TALKING
HEADS ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE, WHO
SPOKE OUT AGAINST THIS, BUT THIS
HAS TO BE UNIVERSAL, SEAN.
WHEN THIS PIPE GUY RECENTLY --
>> Sean: THEY THOUGHT THEY
COULD BLAME THAT ON TRUMP, LIKE
THE SYNAGOGUE SHOOTING, THEY CAN
BLAME ON TRUMP.
THE SHOOTER WAS ANTI-TRUMP
BECAUSE HE IS PRO-ISRAEL.
>> YES!
ANY CONDEMNATION WAS UNIVERSAL
ON OUR SIDE.
PEOPLE HAVE TO SPEAK OUT AND
DRAW A REDLINE AGAINST THIS.
WHAT HAPPENED AT TUCKER'S HOUSE
LAST NIGHT WAS AN ABOMINATION,
IT WAS DISGUSTING.
>> Sean: THERE WAS A REPORT
TONIGHT THAT A CNN ANCHOR
APPARENTLY IS RECEIVING THREATS.
NO CONSERVATIVE -- WE DON'T WANT
YOU, YOU ARE NOT A CONSERVATIVE
IF YOU ARE SENDING THREATS TO
PEOPLE.
PERIOD.
NOW, WE HAVE OVER AT A
CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC, RACHEL
MADDOW IS NOW ENCOURAGING PEOPLE
TO GO OUT AND PROTEST TODAY,
PART OF AN MoveOn.org EFFORT
THAT IS A GENERAL BETRAY US, THE
PEOPLE THAT FEATURED ELDERLY
WOMEN FOLLOWING TWO PRIVATE PART
PUNCH MADE ROMNEY AND BURN THIS
MOTHER F-ERS DOWN.
THIS IS THE NETWORK TOM BROKAW
IS PROUD OF?
THIS PERSON, RACHEL MADDOW,
CLAIMING SHE WAS A NEWS PERSON,
REALLY?
>> SHE IS NOT A NEWS PERSON,
SEAN.
THERE IS A DIRECT LINE BETWEEN
JIM ACOSTA'S BEHAVIOR AT THAT
PRESS CONFERENCE AND WHAT
HAPPENED AT OUR FRIEND IS
TUCKER'S HOUSE, THESE PEOPLE ARE
REPEATEDLY CROSSING THE LINE OF
WHAT IS ACCEPTABLE.
WHETHER YOU ARE A REPORTER IN
THE WHITE HOUSE OR WHETHER YOU
ARE A DEMONSTRATOR IN D.C., THEY
ARE UNDERMINING OR THEY ARE
BROADENING WHAT IS CALLED THE
OVERTON WINDOW, MEANING THE LIST
OF THINGS THAT ARE DEEMED
ACCEPTABLE.
THIS BEHAVIOR -- JIM ACOSTA'S
BEHAVIOR -- THE BEHAVIOR AT
TUCKER'S HOUSE, WOULD HAVE BEEN
DEEMED ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE
JUST TWO YEARS AGO.
MAXINE WATERS --
>> Sean: THEY ARE THROWING UP
DOXING, PUTTING UP ADDRESSES OF
PEOPLE LIKE ME, AND CALLED HER.
I WILL SAY, ANOTHER THING HERE
HERE, -- LOOK, CNN WILL SAY WE
ARE CALLED FAKE NEWS.
THEY ARE, THEY ARE NOT NEWS.
THEY ARE OPINION.
>> LARRY KING SAID IT.
>> Sean: ONE CROWD TO CHANT
"PESACH," THAT IS NOT VIOLENT.
OR THE PRESIDENT SAYS "FAKE NEWS
IS THE ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE," YOU
ARE PERFORMING A DISSERVICE BY
LYING TO PEOPLE.
THAT IS ALL THAT IS.
THOSE ARE WORDS.
THIS IS A CALL TO ACTION, LIKE
MAXINE WATERS.
>> YES, THIS, THIS IS THE DIRECT
RESULT, THE VANDALISM, THE
INTIMIDATION OF A WOMAN BY
HERSELF AT HOME, IS A DIRECT
RESULT OF MAXINE WATERS'
INCITEMENT TO DO THIS, TO HARASS
PEOPLE WHO ARE CONSERVATIVES,
AND ALSO ERIC HOLDER, FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: I WILL GIVE YOU THE
LAST WORD, DAN PAIRED I HAVE A
WORD FOR CONSERVATIVES, DON'T
KICK THEM, DON'T GET IN THEIR
FACES.
IF YOU SEE PEOPLE YOU DISAGREE
WITH.
DON'T CREATE CROWDS, DON'T
FOLLOW PEOPLE INTO STORES, LEAVE
THEM ALONE.
LEAVE THEM ALONE, LEAVE EVERY
LIBERAL ALONE, LEAVE EVERY
REPORTER ALONE.
>> IT DIDN'T WORK THAT WELL FOR
REPUBLICANS IN THE ELECTION AND
THE MIDTERMS.
WHERE WERE THE REPUBLICANS IN
THE STARBUCKS ATTACKING PEOPLE?
THE ANSWER, THEY WERE AT WORK,
GOING TO WORK AND TAKING CARE OF
THEIR FAMILIES.
TAKE A LITTLE LESSON FROM THAT
ON THE FAR LEFT.
IT IS HOW POLITICS SHOULD WORK.
>> Sean: THEY WERE DEAD
SILENT, PAM BONDI, SARAH
SANDERS, SECRETARY NIELSEN, TED
CRUZ, TED CRUZ HIS WIFE, THEY
WERE SILENCED.
IT NOW THEY ARE ACTUALLY